die forelle ein raubfisch in vielen
aquakulturen erhalten die tiere
trockenfutter hergestellt aus kleineren
fischen aus dem meer
doch um die überfischung der meere zu
stoppen wollen wissenschaftler die zucht
forelle zum vegetarier umerziehen
konventionelle fischzüchter sehen das
skeptisch
ein reiner raubfisch der sich zeitlebens
nur von ebene anderen fischen ernährt
hat oder auch vor urzeiten er und den
jetzt im grunde komplett von den enzym
umzustellen auf land lege proteine ja
wer erscheint sehr schwierig schwierig
aber nicht unmöglich
das zumindest sagt karsten schulz
forscher bei der gesellschaft für marine
aquakultur rapsproteine soja und
pflanzenöle das sind die
hauptbestandteile seines vegetarischen
futters es soll den tieren schmecken und
dafür sorgen dass sie kräftig zunehmen
und zum verzehr bestens geeignet sind
doch es geht dabei nicht nur ums fisch
wohl sondern auch um
wirtschaftsinteressen
nur wenn die fische sich ein dickes
polster an fressen lassen sie sich
verkaufen
karsten schulz hatte zuvor mit kartoffel
proteinen experimentiert doch die waren
den forellen zu bitter und wir haben
dort eigene erfahrungen machen müssen
die dieses bestätigen dass der fisch
dann doch lieber zwei monate hungerte
als dass er dann das futtermittel das
versuchs futtermittel aufnahmen weitere
untersuchungen sollen aufschluss geben
wie nahrhaft die vegetarische forelle
für den menschen ist die forscher
ermitteln den fettgehalt im fleisch der
gibt aufschluss über die gesundheit der
tiere
zeigt uns immer an wenn wir sehr fettige
fische haben dass die rohstoffe nicht
optimal verwertet wurden darum ist das
ein ganz wichtiger parameter für uns die
forscher untersuchen auch den
proteinanteil im fisch damit wollen sie
herausfinden wie viel des pflanzlichen
proteinen aus dem neuen futter sich in
das nahrhafte fisch protein verwandelt
hat und damit ist die versuchsreihe noch
nicht abgeschlossen
wir selber konsumieren unsere eigenen
fische her auf wir wollen ja wissen was
wir dort machen und wir stellen
glücklicherweise fest dass durch die
substitution von fischen die durch
pflanzlichen proteine die ja der
geschmack die sensorische qualität nicht
negativ beeinträchtigt wir momentan
reagieren die versuchs vor allen am
besten auf futter mit raps anteil
es laufen aber auch tests mit kartoffeln
und algen teilweise verlängert sich bei
der vegetarischen ernährung der tiere
allerdings ihr wachstum
das heißt sie können erst später
geschlachtet werden
doch innerhalb der nächsten jahre wollen
die wissenschaftler auch das in den
griff bekommen